اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم اشتباكات عنيفه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال في مدينه غزه
وفي خانيونس كتائب القسام تعلن استهداف
حشود اسرائيليه في مدينه غزه بالاشتراك مع
سرايا القدس والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن اصابه
ثلاثه من عسكريه في معارك قطاع غزه خلال
الساعات الماضيه ويفتح تحقيقا في مقتل 12
محتجزا في منزل قصفته بابه اسرائيليه في
كيبوتس بايري يوم السابع من اكتوبر قصف
اسرائيلي متواصل ومكثف على احياء سكنيه في
مختلف ارجاء قطاع غزه استشهاد 107
فلسطينيين خلال 24 ساعه ومسؤول في مستشفى
ناصر بخان يونس يقول للجزيره ان قوات
الاحتلال تواصل حصار المجمع واطلاق النار
في محيطه ويحذر من مصير خطير يواجه مئات
المرضى والاف النازحين هذا في حين حاول
مئات الاسرائيليين عرقله دخول شاحنات
مساعدات عند معبر كرم ابو
سالم وزير الخارجيه الامريكي يواصل جولته
في المنطقه نتنياهو يعلن رفضه اي خطوه
لانهاء الحرب قبل القضاء على حماس وبنك
فير يقول ان على اداره بايدن وقف ضغوطها
في الاثناء قال لابيد انه ابلغ نتنياهو
باستعداده لتامين حمايه للحكومه اذا غادر
بنفير و سموتريتش ورؤساء مجالس مستوطنات
غلاف غزه يحتجون امام مكتب نتنياهو على
المعامله التي يتلقاها السكان والخطه
المقترحه
لعودتهم وفي موضوع ذي صلاه هيئه عمليات
التجاره البحريه البريطانيه تبلغ عن حادث
على مسافه 50 ميلا بحريا جنوبي عدن جماعه
انصار الله تعلن استهداف سفينتين امريكيه
وبريطانيه في البحر الاحمر وتؤكد استمرار
عملياتها ضد الملاحه الاسرائيليه والاهداف
الامريكيه والبريطانيه وواشنطن تقول انها
شنت ضربه للدفاع عن النفس ضد قاربين
مسيرين مفخخين تابعين لانصار الله الى
اللقاء